All right, welcome aboard everybody.
This is Steve at Thousand-Year Homes.
So, out here I'm just solo building. Uh
uh and this is a real world build.
There's not uh you know, bank money and
a whole bunch of money. I'm I'm building
from paycheck to paycheck. Uh just like
uh just like they did 50 years ago. So,
uh and I can only build so much at a
time. So, when you come visit me, I'm
homesteading. I'm building these uh
shipping containers. They're looking
pretty good in thigh, but uh I'm slow.
Uh which is an honest approach,
especially here in Texas where uh the
heat and the drought has been something
fierce. And uh but it rained last night
and it rained really solidly. Um and I'm
it kept me up all night long, so I'm a
little tired. But let's go ahead and
walk around today. See how successful
the rain has been or not. Uh the horses
are up. They're showing me that uh
they're muddy as all get out. So,
they've at least got a little cooling
off. Let's take a look. Okay, let's real
quick just show you what's going on so
you can get an idea as I drive around.
So, uh right here, uh you see there's
the farm. Um this is the satellite image
that's about a year old. So, uh there's
the shipping containers. What I've done
today is I've driven you up to this
stock pond which was dry. So, this one
was mostly dry and we've taken a look at
some other things. First off, uh on this
particular satellite image, if I scroll
in, it doesn't even have the uh pond
that I built right here with here where
I um first off, let me scroll in a
little bit. So, right here is the pond
that I went ahead and just dug and put
the bridge over. So, from the house
walking over now, I have this little
pond right in here in this woods. Uh
there is the um the two gardens that I
have uh right there. So there's the
gardens. So you'll see that I've done a
lot of manage water management already.
So let me go ahead and and zoom back out
for you all so you can see the the
complete property. So the couple of
different things that I'm doing here. So
one thing that I'm doing is I'm uh
building a swale that will run through
here. Let me go ahead and just get brown
up then. So, this swale runs through
here and I'm trying to pick up the water
out of this area. So, I've got a little
swale coming out here and it goes
down and it goes all the way up to here.
So, you can see that this area, if you
look at it closely, that it drains over
to here. So, I'm hoping that I can pick
up all of that water that drains. Now,
this didn't uh drain at all here uh
during this rain, but that doesn't
surprise me because
um you know, we've had a drought. So,
all of this water here that gathers up,
what I want it to do is flow down here,
go through the new bell gate that I
have, run through here, and then find
its way down to here. Now, what I've
decided to do is I've decided to go
ahead and um dig out underneath this
fence and run a couple more swailes down
to here. You can see the cattle are
gathered up just like this. So, I'll
have three swailes that'll be running
down in. Now, these don't exist yet, but
I'll go ahead and do them. But what did
exist and what did work is right here.
You can see there's a wet spot in the
field right right through here. And um
what I'm going to do is I'm going to go
ahead and I put in that test pond right
here. And
um so that test pond is in and it's
successful. And uh you know I've got a
little tiny sweat ditch really that I
just dug over to here and uh it's topped
off right now. So those are uh the
things that I'm doing. I'm trying to
gather up the water here and pipe it
down a swale into the pond. So instead
of this dried up pond, I'll have a
filled one. Then this paddic will have a
pond. That paddic will have a pond. And
then this paddic, what I'll end up doing
is dividing it out. There's a there is a
stream that runs through here, a ditch
rather, that runs through here and dumps
all the water into here and then it all
runs down to Butcher Creek. So what I
want to do is I want to harvest that. So
couple of different things. Right now,
this is spilling spillway through into
the garden and then it'll run over to
here and down. This thing when it tops
off, you could see that it runs this
way. What I want to do is uh one final
pond and it will be a large pond uh that
I'll build and I'll build it over in
um this tree area. And I really want it
to be a a two or three acre pond uh so
that I can capture uh as much water as
possible. Now through the property, I
have a swale that goes here already and
one that runs through here and they both
dump out already right through these
trees where they go through into the
creek. And so I'll be building this pond
eventually. Uh, and I want it to be a
couple acres pond. And I want it to be,
I don't know, 18 ft deep. So, with that,
I'll have a p one, two, three, cuz
hopefully this thing will hold
water. Three ponds. And if I can get it
filled up, I might even do, you know,
expand out the pond a little bit here.
But first, let me dig it deeper and get
these swailes going so it doesn't go dry
in the droughts. And then this pond. And
then these uh swailes here, uh they're
they're working out pretty good. So all
of the uh everything that I'll capture
in these areas, uh you know, all of that
water that I'm going to capture in this
area and run down this swale uh you
know, will dump into that pond. I have
to build these swailes. They don't exist
yet. This one and this one. And that
fence row has got a wall built up along
it. So, the water kind of runs this way
and is escaping into the creek uh like
that. So, anyway, that's what's going on
uh in this little roundabout. So, oh,
the last thing that I did is down here
I'll put NY uh you know, I have the
little stock tank that I put in and it's
only a little bit full. But that's a lot
of different water solutions. And on 3
in, I already picked up a little bit
here. I I filled this off. Uh, this
didn't work here, but it will, right?
The theory is is there. That one worked
really well. This one is sort of kind of
working. And that doesn't exist yet, but
it will. So, um, and this doesn't exist
yet. So, really happy with the overall
water plan. It might take me more than a
year or two to get it done, but I will
get it done. And then during the
drought, uh, you know, July, August,
September, uh, you know, October, I'll
be I'll be digging each one of these
ponds as I can go. Um, the swailes will
be the first thing up here that I'll do
because I've already started them. And,
uh, I want to get seed back on the the
fields as soon as possible. So, without
that uh, further ado, let me jump back
into the video and you guys can watch
the actual physical outcome of this game
plan. All right. So, as my mud beasts
are showing here, we actually had some
rain around here for a change. 3 in is
what my neighbors report. My weather
gauge is not currently working. So, what
I will do is we'll go take a look at the
pond. We'll take a look at some of my
other uh materials. I got to pick up all
of my wet boxes that the uh UPS guy just
left on the side of the road without
plastic bags. That's always pleasant.
So, let's take a look here. Now, one
thing I did wrong was I did not get the
salt block out of the water. So, uh this
is always a bummer when this happened,
but I I leave it evaporate, dump oats in
it. They still get the uh you know, the
salt lick out of
there. But that looks I'm underneath
trees. So, that's looking like 3 in,
right? Maybe even a little more if I
look at that wheelbarrow. Now, let's go
take a look at some other things. Well,
that looks pretty good for a no water
garden. Uh, you know, nothing else grew
in here. I found a composting place for
me to go ahead and put compost over the
top of that box. But, uh, let me tell
you, my uh, it came too late to save
my sunflowers. Either that or the horses
got in there and ate them all. Not sure
what happened there. Disaster on that
sunflower field. I don't see anybody
left.
But they do look eaten rather than
anything else. And I I don't actually
keep the horses out of that. It doesn't
matter to me, but something got that.
Wowee. Well, 3 in is the magic number to
take this from uh dry to filled right
up. This looks really, really good. Uh
man, this year was so dry. It went dry
twice. So, there won't be any frogs in
here that I can think of, unless they
buried themselves in the mud. Uh, I'll
go ahead pull the weeds out of there.
There. I don't like that one.
Weed. Not half bad, everybody. So, those
have been I'll get some pictures of this
when it's dry so you all can appreciate.
Now, I have seen this as a running water
and it runs this way. So, what I'm doing
here is uh from the um uh pond, I'm
going to make a swale. And I'm slowly
working on it. And the swale will go
around and it'll go around
here. And if you look there into the
garden, you could see that I've got a a
swale beginning where the water will go
flow into the gardens and and then out
that way to a
river. Looks really good. But oh my
gosh, I have been I might be able to
make it this year for water for my
horses without having to bother my poor
neighbors anymore. That's really really
good. This side I I've got I put gypson
in it and so this side ends up getting
clear. And uh I might do the same thing
to that pond. My chickens are out in the
in the forest.
All right, let's go ahead and get a uh
in my uh UTV and go and drive and see
what else we've got going on
here. All right. Well, I'll tell you
this rain really changed my mood. I I I
just can't do in five months we got like
two inches of rain. I I just couldn't do
it anymore. I I'm not built that way.
And uh I grew up in Michigan where you
know land of lakes and there rains all
the time and uh I never have adapted to
Texas and to be honest when I watch
everything die that I plant it uh gives
me a a heap and helping of depression.
So I'm very much a creature of my
atmosphere very much connected to the
land and uh you know it doesn't take
much just some rain to cheer me up and a
full stock tank. Uh, this thing is
working out. Um, and I I wondered if it
would. That's just three inches. So, if
it rained a normal amount, I could dig
this out even bigger and deeper and have
a um, you know, I would still keep the
front for the horses to wait into. So,
it's a ramp there, but the rest of this
I would dig out uh, pretty deep and
pretty narrow. I try to retain as much
moisture as I can. But, uh, this end of
the house I'm real happy with. I've got
grass seed. I've got long stem uh uh you
know, blueg grass to plant and some
other things uh natives uh grass seed
here. I'll put it in the ground. Um it's
supposed to maybe rain again this week.
Now, I'm not declaring victory. I'm
fully expecting uh to see, you know, uh
the gr dr dr dr dr dr dr dr dr dr dr dr
dr dr dr dr dr dr dr dr drought continue
through, you know, July, August,
September. But it was over 101 degrees
in the summer here and everything that I
had was was dying. Uh the horses were
having to hang around me all day long
and um because the grass is too stringy
when it doesn't get any moisture in it
and it's really hard to graze. So I was
feeling their
complaint. And uh anyway, I'm I'm so
much happier with this. Let's go up and
we'll take a look at my test uh stock
tank that I dug as well as my swale that
I put in to try to redirect more water.
I I don't know if it got enough rain for
that or not, but we'll find out
together.
Well, there's a whole herd of buzzards
here. I don't know
why they're still roaming around. I
don't see anything for them to be
eating. Maybe they were just having a
convention.
That there is all of the cedar that I'll
end up stripping for uh coyote fence.
I'm just moved it out of my way so that
uh the needles can fall off of it and I
can go through. I also uh will run this
over with my brush hog. It can run up to
3-in uh size logs. So, that's how I uh I
mulch it, right? So, I'll turn that all
into
mulch. Sure made the field look a lot
better.
I did get grass uh head. So, uh
hopefully it'll recede. The cattle
haven't been out here because there's no
water for them to drink. This stock tank
I'm coming up to has been
empty. And the cattle, if they did use
it, they would have had the trunk in the
mud knee deep, and that's not safe.
[Music]
Yeah. Yeah. So, uh, for reference, the,
uh, the pond used to be up to the bottom
of that tree right there. Right. So, uh,
it got a little water. It was all
cracked and and whatnot, but not nearly
enough. Let me see if my swale work.
Doesn't look like flowing water went
into it. It looks like the idea might
work, but I'm just going to have to cut
it in deeper.
Some shallow spots there.
All right. So, that uh bit of rain
wasn't enough to cause runoff here along
uh that old Pioneer Road that used to be
a road that would go to a dip tank as
well as some other go off in church or
wherever it went. I don't know.
So, that feels like my pond idea there
uh might work, but uh I'm going to
require more than 3 in of rain after 5
months of drought, right?
Yeah, I don't see anything that
happened. Just wasn't enough rain. Oh,
I'm
wrong. Oh, lookucky
there. Well, that's a 4 and 1/2t hole.
I'm going to take a look at it right
now. Pretty pretty excited. My idea did
work.
Like I say, that's a 4ft test
hole,
huh? Well, all
right. Well, I'll scrape the land with
my uh my little tractor and I'll make a
little halfacre pond here. All right.
Wow. Wow, man. That that would be
awesome. I would have
uh I would have then
two ponds. Uh I'd have this pond, I
would have that pond in these paddics.
So each paddic would have a pond. Man,
that is exciting
stuff. All right, another success that
I'm super happy about. Lookie, you know,
that was just a a wild hair that I got
that um based on the lay of the land and
how it ran into this aoyo over here. If
I can hijack it and get it to come it
and I could put a pond in here and uh
look uh that I did it. So, uh, the the
plan will be a similar size pond with a
a decent ramp for the cattle to come in,
but narrow and deep in order to kind of
keep as much water as possible. Now,
I'll be losing a little bit of uh of
pasture to this pond, but it'll more
than make up for it because uh I'll be
able then to close off both paddics and
then I can density graze each one. So,
the cattle and horses um they'll they'll
last a little longer. So, my bell way
down there where I'm slowly working on
the fence uh uh I I might get excited
about and finish up. But now that it's
cooler, uh I'll be I'll be back on the
sawmill. Uh I just couldn't handle the
tin there. Too hot. But uh this is super
exciting. I feel like I've won. And uh
you know, that's not a mud uh just a mud
puddle. That thing's 4 foot deeper. So
I'll put some uh some of the video of me
digging that. Uh super exciting, man. I
am happy about that. So and so will the
wildlife. They'll they'll appreciate
that little little drinking spot and so
will the cattle. Ah, just so
happy. Well, I'm pretty happy with the
results of what little bit of uh water
collection I've got going on here. I've
been working on it for a few years. The
first year I wasn't out here living. Uh
I had an apartment, but uh I went and
collected uh you know, images and paid
attention and came out. So, my last bit
of uh water is this tank. And Leah and I
went ahead and repaired it, and it was
dry. I can see that it's uh gosh, not
not very full, just the 3 in. Now, I was
expecting to collect more water than
that from there. But what I'll do is
I'll get aluminum tape and I'll tape
along the gutter and the uh convolution.
I think I'm losing, you know, half the
water um through each one of the uh uh
ridges and peaks of the corrugation. So,
I'll go ahead and tape that up so that I
can capture more water. This was just
all juryrigged right now temporarily. I
want to I've got I found enough uh um uh
eaves to run the other side. I'll put a
bulkhead here. Rebuild this. I need this
to be about half full so before I can um
uh go ahead and put the walls around it
because uh I'm expecting it to change
shape once it gets filled with water. So
I was hoping more would be in there than
the the 3 in. But I'm grateful for the
three that are there. Uh I can see based
on the bottom there's water underneath
it causing a little uh you know can't
burp out of there etc etc. But, uh, I'll
just live with it the way it is. Once I
get it full, then I can, you know, use
this for agricultural, keep my gardens
green, uh, get some additional trees out
here. That was destroyed. Destroyed in
the storm. Destroyed. It was already
torn up, but the roof was still there.
So, win some, lose some, but all that
will be moved when I'm done with the
sawmill area. I've got enough storage in
there. I can move all of that. And so,
I'll get the sawmill all set up way back
yonder. uh working hard doing a lot of
different things but uh when the when
the heat is the way it is and it's over
101 and you know you can't touch tin and
all I'm doing is working with metal and
uh it's hard for me to keep positive
energy going so you know I look for
little jobs to do like clearing a tree
or something like that uh working at the
front on the gate just little things
like that but they're not forward
progress on the li on the living
arrangement
uh which this year I've got high
ambitions to get the real foundations
underneath here as well as the roof,
etc., etc., etc. And daylight's burning
and uh we'll see if I can accomplish
this. So, a little bit of work here to
do on the uh you know, I want to make
sure that this thing catches all the
water it can and fills up. Uh so, I'll
be working on that. I might cut across
here and grab that one, too, and see if
I can double up the capacity. Uh, I
should be getting about 340 gallons per
inch of rain off of there and maybe uh,
you know, that's a 5,000galon tank, so
you know, it takes a lot of water to
fill it up. Uh, but I need it at least
half filled so that the walls are pushed
out so that I can earth bag it about and
stuckco it and, you know, not make it an
eyesore. It's an eyesore. Uh, but it's
an eyes sore because uh I got to get
that yet. I don't have any water out
here. I'm a dry cabin. So, I got to get
that filled up with some water so that
it's the right size and then I can fix
it up, make it look nice, fix up the
bulkheads, uh, you know, do these eaves.
They're temporary, too. So, they're just
up there with magnets. Uh, there's a lot
of things to do, but I'm pretty excited
about this bit of rain. I appreciate it
much. uh really changed my moods and uh
grateful to God because I
complain. I have a relationship with God
that's very vocal and uh so you know uh
I appreciate the rain being out here and
fill it up and hopefully it'll continue
on.